Explorers opened up the world all around, these fearless men.
We have done well in all hemispheres.
Their great audacity made us an offering of the earth.
Yes, these knights, I tell you, have never wavered, have never weakened the explorers.
Nothing can stop them, neither wind nor storm.
These men of heart have no backdrop but a beautiful sky of stars.
The dream of outdoing their fools and without worrying about jealousy.
They sail forward.
Explorers sailed valiantly across the oceans, navigating them with hearts that were truly brave.
their little black shells were really no match for storms. On the raging waves,
their temerity was clearly demonstrated. Explorers always reveal new things to us with breath,
rejecting fear, refusing all fear of adventures by swearing, to return this money and offer the
sum to souls. In 1528, 15 years after Leon, another conquistador, Panelo de Narvaz,
was tasked with prospecting Florida. His assistant and treasurer for this expedition was me,
Cabeça v. Florida is close by.
Governor Narvaaz, it seems that the Indians there are welcoming.
So much the better, so much the better.
They would make very good slaves.
We could try to make Christians out of them instead, couldn't we, Governor?
H. I have plenty of Christians and no slaves at all.
Cabeça.
Oh, but.
You, Cabeça, you are only the treasurer of this expedition, so remember that.
What interests us most is the gold and the slaves who bring in a lot of gold.
Full stop, it's all.
Land on board.
Capture them.
But governors, these people treat us as friends.
Why are you doing this?
I want slaves.
Do you understand?
Go ahead.
Catch them.
Get them.
Get him.
He's very strong.
He'll probably make a good slave.
No.
Stop.
You can see he seems friendly.
Orders are orders.
Look what I found.
Here's something to eat.
Look, chief.
Keep some gold.
Some gold.
Find out where we can find some.
I need prisoners and don't hesitate to shoot them.
Let him know who's boss now.
You see, chief, they were friendly and now they've become aggressive.
And first of all, shut up, I know what I have to do.
So where did this gold come from?
Are you going to tell me?
Appalachian, Appalachian, Calusa, Appalachian.
Yes, that's it.
I think I've figured it out according to him when it's over these hills in Appalachian
country.
So let's go, let's go.
But we can't abandon our ships.
We'll have to find them a port.
And we don't have any food to go on an adventure inland.
Food?
We'll find some among the natives, that's for sure.
When we're in Naveen, we'll just have to follow the coast to find a port where we can join them.
What do you think, gentlemen?
Question mark.
Since we've agreed, we'll leave tomorrow at dawn.
He's a great chief, our chief, we must obey him.
A few years ago, Cortes beat him soundly, our great chief.
Yes, at St. Pola in the south of the country.
Is that right?
Yes.
So, he has some revenge to take after that, our great chief.
And the next day, we left without a home port, without knowing where we were going, without food.
We left to die almost all of us.
over to you come on hello hello i said me come on my friend i'm going to build rafts oh that
narvis is crazy come on chick let's go back let's go come on come on watch out friends there's a
strange animal there it looks like a big cat a very big cat it's good or bad well in palach
there were only about 40 small houses made of straw and leaves interwoven together which hug
the thick bush. The men have left. We'll be able to search for gold in peace. There's no gold here.
You're going to tell me where the gold is, huh? And look. He asked for their wives and children
to be returned to them. You say it's cold. Yes, that's it, chief. The village is a nine or ten
day walk away. Chief, they said it's near the sea and it's rich in corn, beans and fish. What do
you think, gentlemen? Every day, our men and horses are being injured and killed. We have to leave
here and food will soon run out. And we left without knowing where we were going towards our
destiny. Okay, let's go. We need to find food or we'll all die here. We can't be far from Ute's
village. Let's hope so now. So, we've mistreated them, so they've destroyed everything. All we have
to do is die. No, governor, we just have to build boats and head out to sea. You're crazy. We have
nothing to build boats with, no iron, no rope, no tools. I, chief, can make a forge. And I'm a
carpenter. I know how to make glue to seal a boat. So, let's get to work, my children. We can melt
these stirrups, can't we? And this armor and the crossbow as well as the spears. This halberd in
the forge. Come on. These men had no tools, had never built a ship before. They showed great
ingenuity. In less than two months, five sailing boats were finished. Nothing more to see. We must
have faith in our lord. He will come to our aid. Land ahead. Rower Sue closes. We must find water.
Otherwise we are all dead.
You will go over there, you on this side and I will go over there.
No water.
There is not a drop and nothing to eat.
But be blessed, Lord.
You have not abandoned us.
They want to take us, feed us and then sacrifice us to their God.
He seems rather well-meaning and they have just saved our lives.
Oh, do you really think they are friendly?
Well, let's go.
When we have regained some strength, we will see.
We have been here for a month already.
We have eaten well and regained all our strength.
We still have weapons and they have none.
We will be able to subdue all these savages.
My chiefs, they have shown themselves to be kind and they would make very good Christians.
They are savages, they are pagans.
I say they will make very good slaves.
And then, I remind you that I am the one in charge.
So, be quiet and wait for my orders.
They are, sulking, they are sulking.
Eat, drink, come over there, take hold.
Look at the storm rising, and straight ahead.
He is bringing us food.
Here, it is the women, sometimes the old men, who work and carry the loads.
To have a daughter, a father is given a bow and two or three arrows.
There is so little to eat in this country that it takes all the ingenuity of the Indians to manage to feed themselves.
Everything is good for them.
Ants, they are ants, spiders, green, lizards, salamanders, snakes, vipers and even if there is nothing else, wood or earth.
Yes, yes, wood or earth.
There are also roots in the marshes that are quite good to eat.
But what a terrible job it was to have to gather them, which was one of our tasks.
Now, the Indians are criticizing us for not wanting to cure them.
And because of this, they refuse to feed us.
And yes, they don't want to understand that it's not that we don't want to,
it's that we don't know how.
You who are as wise as Abba, maybe you should try something.
Yes, yes, you just have to pretend.
It might work.
Anyway, we have to leave this place.
So, we'll leave tonight and take advantage of their sleep.
We'll just take a little food from them to survive.
Look! What is that? What a strange bird. It doesn't fly.
Listen, I have the impression that there are men approaching.
Yeah, that's right, and they have light skin, which means they have the power to cure diseases.
Oh no, curing diseases is my business here.
I don't want to compete. We'll kill them all.
But in the meantime, I have a patient to treat.
So, do you still have a stomachache?
Oh yes, the pain has lasted for over two days.
I'm going to treat you.
You see, that's a good sign.
The smoke is carrying away the pain, so it's better now.
Oh no, it's nothing.
It still hurts, but it's not the same pain as before.
Okay, I'm stopping the treatment.
We'll see about that a little later.
So now, I have to say that it's better.
Oh yes, it's definitely better.
You see, he's better.
You don't need another medicine man.
We could still try.
Yes, yes, I hear that they are international specialists.
We've been, waiting for you, you great doctors, we need you, but we're not doctors, I don't
know anything about it, it's terrible, it's, nothing at all, I have enough to heal you,
even though I'm in a, miserable state, wait, wait, sorcerer, we must let foreigners do
their thing, but we don't know, faith can heal, I'll try, our father in heaven, have
mercy on this poor fisherman, be so kind as to take away from him this pain that overwhelms
him. Oh lord of mercy. Disappear. Pain. Vatan. Leave this man's head. Free his spirit. Von.
You filthy fart that you are. Gone. That's it. My pain is gone. No more. That's witchcraft.
That's not real medicine. I'm going to practice elsewhere. Tuna. What is it, tuna? It's happiness.
We eat it. We make fish out of it. But you'll see tomorrow. Tunas. Not bad. We must be all
the rage there and if we try there strange people what a great idea to dance on one foot what's that
oh that's nothing it's just an antelope hair a hair but i didn't see anything no wonder this
hair is the fastest animal in existence and that's why we can't see it look it's coming back
but it's so fast that we can't see it how can you know what it is since you've never seen it
ah that's a good question sometimes we can see it do you want me to show you oh yes yes i'd like
to. You'll see. Oh. Oh. There. You can see it but look quickly. Oh. If we treat them, we can make
them pay. That's worth gold. Emeralds. Precious stones. It's the lord who treats them. He got an
arrowhead right in the back. Oh. Extractor. Ah. That hurts a lot. I think we need to administer
anesthesia. Full anesthesia. You can go. Doctor. Needle and thread for two stitches. Surgery over.
patient resuscitation. He's doing much better. I'm cured. Yeah. A little further on, there's a big
river and even further on, there are mountains. And there, there are also white men like you.
We can't take it anymore. We haven't eaten for two days. We're dying of thirst. We'll help you.
This big river separates two countries. Over there, it's the land of cows and over here,
the land of corn. We'll follow the setting sun. They say there's another ocean. Maybe we'll be
lucky enough to find our people there. Other Spaniards, I mean. My arm is twisted. It doesn't
work anymore. Oh, it's dislocated. We need to put it back together. It's your turn, Stephanie Co.
Oh, it works. It works. It's been going on for ages. And it's getting on my nerves. It's getting
on my nerves. Torticollis Sinister with a twisted third facial nerve. Okay, Stephanie Co. Start
procedure number 18. Strength 4. Okay, I'm going to do it, professor. I told you strength 4. You're
going way too hard. You're going to give him an extra torticolide now to treat with procedure 19.
But go easy, that includes a half dose, okay? It took Cabesa and his companions six years to cross
America from east to west. Almost 6,000 kilometers, almost always on foot, without any weapons,
without food or clothing. Healing was their one and only weapon and so they learned to use it.
The enemy is that other Spaniards were arriving from the south and they had completely different
ambitions. We know that you come here as a friend of our people, so welcome among us. May you stay
long. Thank you. Thank you, my friends. But you see, we have heard that white men like us are
barely a few days. Walk from your village and we want to find them. So, if that's the case,
our people will accompany you because these men can be terribly dangerous. Finally, slaves,
it's not too soon. Grab them. We are free men, Spaniards, just like you are. Spaniards, huh?
Never seen them like that in my life as a Spaniard.
I am Alvarez Numescavesa de Vaca, treasurer of the expedition that was undertaken by Governor Narvaez.
I am Alonso del Castillo, lieutenant of the king.
I, Andrantes, am an officer of the Spanish Guard.
My name is Esteban Nicomor from Morocco and Spanish soldiers.
Huh? Cab, we thought he was dead.
Well, no. Here we are with the help of our lord and that of our friends the Indians.
Well, at least they will make good slaves.
Oh no, these are my friends, the free men.
I'm joking, of course, you see.
Yes, Cabeza was the most humane of all the campistadors.
He discovered and described with passion the most unknown regions ranging from Florida to California and Mexico.
He took the trouble to try to get to know the Indians, to become attached to them.
Bravo! At least that's one story of a conquistador that ends well.
Oh, not so much, because alas, like all the others, Cabeza will experience that curse of the conquistadors that I told you about.
Imprisoned because he loved the Indians too much, he will rot away almost until the end of his days.
Lawyers discovered the world, made the earth round.
Innovators will still find paths to trace and then offer them to souls as one offers a beautiful woman to you, to us, to me, I believe.
Ah!